welcome to this video I'm playing do it
now I have some I pin it against this
time and there was something happening
don't remember I think I think it's much
about the games where I really was
totally lost and then somehow got back
into the game due to some mistake okay
I'm Bishop t2 played okay yeah this is a
rare rare line here of the bogo but ok
it seems to be check leading to a fairly
normal position where to go yeah yep
only 37 and so not clear to me sometimes
you also have be eight sometimes this is
really a good idea get down get the
night to be aid okay here maybe b6 going
to get for some counter play going to
get going to go for some counter play it
is quite often an idea to take on d5 and
play 97 to be Phi of this kind of
activation well maybe maybe Bishop g4
first to provoke f3 and then back can be
an idea also and yeah I can maybe if i
take here can maybe take with the e pawn
okay maybe this also be 5 can be can be
interesting to try okay yeah don't know
if I should take maybe first provoke
this f3 move and then drop back
okay if I now take he will take with the
sea pawn that's pretty clear I guess now
I have Bishop to b5 but it's not really
a grade and maybe be five before first
OS was quickly played okay yeah I guess
I should take the the rook on the FR
should should be activated I'm not sure
about this before move maybe it is ok
but I didn't really expect that to
happen
okay yeah where to put this may be here
for him not clear cannot take it
unfortunately where would be nice get
something on the dark squares but not
going to happen yeah what can be an idea
my map this is this is covered maybe I
should do this night be 64 cook it could
be okay I have a pretty solid structure
don't have any substantial weaknesses b5
is reliably covered by the bishop on d7
and you cannot really attack d6 his
peace bishop on g2 is not great it could
be an idea to put it on everyone trying
to pressurize be higher but i'm going to
play Knight be 64 in any case okay so
here yeah but still I would take take I
can't play 94 and then neither upon
coming to c 6 is really a very
unsupported unit with the night being on
see why this is actually quite nicely I
think should be quite nice for me on
Queen a five maybe and then rook c8 yeah
looks like decent choice yeah yeah I
have this check mmm which maybe is not
doing much
check okay but anyway it's a slight
improvement for the Queen I guess would
be some covering c6 what can I do to
improve here the knight on f6 probably
could be involved in the queenside the
queenside play yeah not quite sure how
exactly the knight on f6 should be
activated 98 c 7 it's not clear that
this really leads to anything
maybe he can play knight c6 somehow
using the situation in with the b5 point
the bishop on everyone I really don't
see how but maybe
I'm not not sure how to improve this
position this is not just a passive move
our cautious move I was thinking that
maybe g5g for can be an idea but maybe
is this is a totally unrealistic and
possible yeah probably it is Syria
unrealistic but okay kingi to it at
least it protected his son his structure
here they have to pawn
yeah it's not an easy position to play I
understand that he is not playing this
very quickly a knight on f6 and now
maybe g5 is really crazy but some more
like the idea especially considering his
very limited time line now before hangs
right can just can just take the piece I
don't really know it here spending lots
of times the position wasn't easy to
play i mean this this night on c4 i look
on a4 they they always slightly slightly
annoying around here i think should this
should be really ok for black check sure
what shouldn't be in any trouble it's
just not so easy to play always facing
those two active pieces that that
irritate you played here and I could
have played 92 m I completely forgot
that yeah of course if three is hanging
I was only looking at night a three
sometimes here attacking the Queen and
keeping an eye on the the night but here
there is f1 and and this says is a bit
much I think he needs to maybe go here I
don't know I threatened to take this was
check so something like this once wins
big material him okay this this was
already possible g5 is given by the
computer immediately so I wow
I was doing it more conservatively but
it's the computer move amazing so I
probably had the right right hand ship
and this is plundering the the night
yeah there's this idea it's not totally
a revolutionary that I using the Jeep on
to soften up the the center still led
sometimes tough to play because you
expose your own king but it's a seems to
be good here and it's in fact the
computer choice okay thanks for watching